Now we're going to actually
install our workshop,
which is the Android Studio program.
I suggest you watch me so that you
can have a sense of what the process
looks like, and then follow the text
version instructions at your own pace.
Also, keep in mind that
these are large files.
You're going to want to have a strong
and stable Internet connection.
For students with slower and
more unreliable Internet,
you might want to consider finding
a wired Internet connection.
Also, if things are taking
a while to load or download and
you're getting bored, feel free to go to
the next node, which has a quick review
quiz game that you can do while
Android Studio is downloading.
I've created the walkthrough for
how to download Android Studio on
two different operating systems.
I have instructions for Windows and
instructions for Mac computers.
I'll give you a moment.
Go ahead and
click on which one applies to you.
Okay, I'm going to be installing
Android Studio on a Windows machine.
Please note that this screen cast
was done on April 7, 2015 and
I say that just because sometimes the
screens or the icons that you might see
while installing Android studio could
change depending on what version it is.
We're going to give you a text version
to go along with the screencast.
Since it's easier to change the text
version than to go through re-recording
an entire screencast,
that will be a little it more up
to date than the screencast will.
All right, so to start off,
go ahead and open a web browser, and
go to the Android studio website.
It's linked in the instruction notes,
you do not have to type this in.
All right, so once you've arrived on
the site, you should see a big green
button that's pretty obvious that says
Download Android Studio for wWndows, so
go ahead and click that.
All right and that's going to take you
to the License for Android Studio.
You're welcome to go ahead and
read that.
I'm going to scroll to the bottom,
sign my rights away,
and then click this Download
Android Studio for Windows button.
All right, we did want to download this,
so we do want to keep it.
I'm going to press Keep.
Okay, and if you look right here, this
is a little bit less than a gig of data.
And that's about equivalent to
downloading a movie file of
reasonable quality.
So you can judge how long this will
take based on your Internet connection.
Okay, once it's finished downloading,
go ahead and double click the file.
We did in fact want to run this.
So click Run.
Yes, we did want to allow
it to make changes.
All right, and now we're at
the Android Studio Setup Wizard.
This is going to guide you through
a collection of screens to set up
Android Studio, and pretty much always
we're going to just select the default.
All right, so I'm going to hit Next,
I want all these boxes checked.
Note that this requires 3.8 GB of space,
and we only download about a gigabyte,
so after this, there's going
to be even more downloading.
I'm going to hit Next.
This is a license agreement here, you
can go ahead and read it if you'd like.
I'm going to go ahead and hit I Agree.
Oh yes, I agree more.
Okay, I'm all right with all of
these standard install locations.
All right,
going to say next on the emulator setup.
We'll talk about this later.
Sure, let's make a Start Menu folder and
I'm going to hit Install,
which will bring me to this screen.
Of course, if you like staring
at loading bars feel free.
All right, it looks like it completed.
I can go ahead and
look at the show details.
And I'm not seeing anything here
about huge errors, so that's good.
All right, I'm going to go ahead and
click Next.
Okay, so the install looks like
it finished, we click finish.
This is the little loading screen for
Android Studio when it starts up.
Okay, now this is asking me if I have
some settings from a previous version of
Android Studio, and
I'm pretty sure that you don't.
So you probably want to hit the I don't
have a previous version of android
studio, or I don't want to import my
settings, and go ahead and hit OK.
Just going ahead and downloading
a few more components for me.
Now once you see this screen,
you know you've got
Android Studio up and running.
But the real test to see if
you did everything correctly
will be if you can make
your first app using it.
All right, so
this completes the installation video.
And now you're going to do
this process on your own.
All right, I'm going to download
Android Studio on a Mac.
Note that this screen cast
was done April 6th, 2015.
And the reason I'm saying
that is because sometimes,
this process will change.
We will always provide you
with text instructions for
the install process, and we will
keep those instructions up to date.
So things look a little
different here and there.
Don't worry, check out the text
install instructions and
with that little mini
note let's get started.
The first thing you're going to do is
click at the instructed note below
to get to the Android studio homepage.
Don't try typing this out, just click
the link in the instructor notes.
Once you're here there's going to be a
pretty obvious button that says download
Android studio and it should say for
Mac, go ahead and click it.
At this point you'll see a license
agreement, you can read it if you like.
And then go ahead and scroll down,
click that you've read it and
then click this download
Android Studio for Mac button.
Okay, so
it's started downloading here for me.
Now you should be able to see that this
download is a couple hundred megabytes.
Once it's downloaded,
go ahead and double-click it.
You should see this big beautiful
screen that says Android studio.
And as with most applications, you're
going to go ahead and click Android
studio and drag it into your
applications folder so it'll copy over.
After you've successfully done that,
you can go ahead and
double click Android Studio, which will
actually try to open Android Studio.
You might get a warning about it
being a download from the web.
But we did mean to download this and
we did mean to run it so go ahead and
click Open.
This little screen should appear to
load up the installation process.
All right, and
here we are at the Welcome Wizard.
What follows is going to be a series
of screens and licenses and
you pretty much just want
to keep the defaults.
And you click Next.
This is a screen asking me where
my Java development kit is.
Now, we just installed that and
it's actually making
a guess about where it is.
If it isn't guessing,
you can click the Detect button.
And if that isn't working, you can
try navigating your file system to go
exactly to where you downloaded it.
If you're having trouble with this step,
It probably means that there were
issues with downloading
the Java Development Kit.
You might have downloaded
the wrong file or
just something might not
be configured right.
Try going through
the instructions again or
checking out
the troubleshooting documents.
Everything seems to be working here so
I'm going to go ahead and click Next.
Now we're not doing
anything too crazy so
I'm going to choose
a standard installation.
Here are some of the licenses
that I was talking about.
Go ahead and click on this
first license and say, Accept.
That'll accept all these
licenses down here.
You'll have to click on the next
license set here, and also hit Accept.
And this will let you finish
the Android Studio Setup Wizard.
Okay, when I click Finish, it's actually
going to download a lot of stuff.
And what all of this entails is
downloading a couple gigs of data,
which is sort of a huge
amount of stuff to download.
So be patient,
this might take some time.
If you're getting bored of staring at
a loading bar, you can go ahead and
click to the next video, where we.
We have a little review game to go over
some of the stuff we've already learned.
As you see this window, go ahead and
type in your password, and
the candy cane strips here
mean this is close to done.
Awesome.
And
once you're done, you see this screen.
Hopefully there's a lot of positive
language like successfully,
installation pass, successfully created.
If you see any errors here it could
mean that there are errors with
the installation.
But things look good so
I'm going to go ahead and click Finish.
Now once you see this screen, you know
that you've got Android studio up and
running, so great job.
But the real test is going to be seeing
if we did everything correctly enough
that we can create out
own apps using it.
All right, so,
now you've watched me do the steps once.
I want you go ahead and
download Android Studio yourself.
If the downloading is taking awhile, but
you still want to be doing Android stuff
feel free to move onto the next node
where we have a review game to pass
the time while things install.